So now that we have seen how to access the BTB, let's do a quiz.
Let's say we have a BTB with 1,024 entries. Note that these entries
will be number 0 through 1,023. Let's say that this particular architecture uses
fixed-size 4-byte instructions that have to be word-aligned. Which means,
an instruction needs to begin at the divisible by four address. So,
an instruction can be at address 0, 4, 8, etc.
But it cannot be at addresses something like 3, or 5, or 17. And
let's say that the program counter is a 32-bit register, meaning that this
particular processor uses 32-bit instruction addresses. The question for you,
is which BTB entry, again, they're numbered from 0 to 1,023, should be used for
PC, whose address is x0000AB0C? Write your answer here.
Again, the answer should be between 0 and 1023.